はいどうもーーーーyeahhhhhh
ダンカンさんだああああああああ
PDRさんのダンカンさんの家に今日は遊びに来てるっす
よろしくお願いします
なんか嫌そうな顔ですけどね
ま、ということで今日はですね
PDRさん：１００個何か食べるの？
はじめ：今日は１００個食べないです
PDR：２００個？
はじめ：２００個も食べないです今日は大丈夫です
今日はねPDRさんの家に遊びに来てるというわけでね
ま、あるゲームをしようと思います
ガチムチミルクバトル
ィェーーーーーーーーイ
はい、ルールは簡単でございます
今からPDRさんと僕が交互に一人づつ口に牛乳を含みます
牛乳というわけでね
例えば先にPDRさんが牛乳含んでて
僕がそれを笑わせにいきます
PDRさんが吹いたら僕の勝ちです
ま、僕にかかっちゃうんですけど
僕が口に牛乳含んでる時は
PDRさんが僕を笑わせに来て
堪えれば僕の勝ちです
吹いたらPDRさんの勝ちです
というね今日本当に初対面なんですけど
本当によろしくお願いします
*じゃんけんタイム*
準備いいですか？ではいきます
3 2 1
スタート
くくくっ
^^;
＾＾；
ｗ
ＷＷＷＷＷＷＷＷＷＷＷＷＷＷＷ
ｗｗ
ゴルゴンゾーラ　ゴルゴンゾーラ
テキサス州
カルふぉるにあ　ラーメン
カキの実　パイの実　どっちどっち
wwwwwww
はいというわけで完全な僕の勝ちですね
wwwwwwwwwww
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
というわけでまずは僕の一勝目ってことで
僕もいきます
？？
ダンカンさんくらいの笑いなら僕は耐えれますよ全然
wwwww
ww
wwwwwwwwwwwwwwwww
wwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwww
ED
wwwwwwwww
はいというわけでね
今回はね引き分けということになっちゃったんですけども
PDRさん機会があればまたよろしくお願いします
家でやるときはちゃんと親の許可を取りましょう
8888888
バーイ！！！！